[Music]
hi mom it's your sister like roaches in
your nothing who is this oh I gotta go
Tanya Manimal mining here goes she's
never even seen it
we're pretty sure that the guy who
talked to isn't real I saw bridesmaids I
will take a [ __ ] in his dress please
don't do that best way to get over a man
is to get up under a new wind watch and
learn
there's a bow on the back there Frank
has been trying to take you out for like
three years go out with it you are
addressing me with your ass my nipples
are getting out everything sighs excuse
me
Mama's Anika put me out this connection
is so reckoning hello mama you know I'm
sorry what we don't know cell phone line
I can't hear you baby I can't hear
absolutely come on come we're back I
appreciate you trying to I salute you
but my sister is a bit much again what
you want me to put right there you know
great what you want to put plenty
position which one do you want me to be
in what position you want to be in uh
well you know I prefer doggy style do
you see more like a missionary but you
know what I could show you the spider
you ever heard about the spiny de spider
hanging on end about that this legs
everywhere heck just leave just hi mommy
I need your help
it's your sister she's good now mom
she's better now and God and she's clean
ah darling would you do me a favor would
you please go and pick her up she asked
me to come get her in my car but my
car's not doing so well I'll pick her up
after work and we'll be by your house by
6:00 how you bring her in my house for
mommy do you realize that the last time
she stayed with me all my copper was
gone I don't know how she got it out the
wall I don't know how she got it out the
toast of my QVC toast of my favorite
toaster you just said that she was clean
I was clean enough to go to your house
mama
mama is Tanya who it's Tanya oh no Tanya
no here mama I know it's you know it's
you know here either
mama hear you at the window I don't know
I don't know mama I know it's you
well what do you want mom I need a place
to stay
Tanika put me out you smoked it we know
I have arthritis is a hereditary
I'm know inside the right is why did you
put you out she mad at me cuz she got
catfished I guess you just gotta call
her mama I just told you she put me out
huh you know it's so funny that this
connection is so reckoning hello what
mama you in the window
I can't you baby I can't mama where must
a mama where look on mama mama mama this
are teaches you right here okay they
don't smell like roaches in your nothing
this is something and look at this huh
how you give sparkles in the back of an
animal this is a kid man
thank you
Hey well is he today it's a normal
Monday
how'd you radio Frank here your money's
no good you got to stop doing this I
have to pay this food Mia you're gonna
lose your business and the rose I told
you I do have a boyfriend I'm well aware
see you tomorrow
[Music]
I have always dreamed of Whoopi Goldberg
being my mom I felt like she probably
the best mom for me like if I could have
been like if I could have been like a
little salt up in heaven and guy said
well who do you want to be your mama
ought to be like give me whooping give
me would be to be my mama and he could
ever say I feel like I would've been
like well you gonna get your ass beat
that's cool god I could deal with that I
just want to learn how to be a more
mature successful person Lord and then
Lord be like all right but that's not
what happened God was like I'm getting
this mama
Chico beat us to it and you know I'm
grateful for the mom that he did give me
but I still have always dreamed of
Whoopi Goldberg being my mom and then
you might hear something crazy
so when I read the script I thought
Tyler Perry was doing research on me
because I never see my mama's name out
in public right and I tell you right now
my mom my real mother's name is Leola
and when I saw the script and he said
Lola I was like cause people call my mom
Lola and I was like dude has he been did
he put on my birth certificate like
what's really going on and then like two
weeks before we started filming he tells
me that Whoopi Goldberg is gonna be my
mama did not start i like hung up the
phone with him and i easily start crying
and i instantly
sobbing like oh god you've been
listening to me audience yes and i love
would be like the first time I met her
I'm so happy and I remember the first
time I went to do the view is she wasn't
there I was so upset I was so bad I was
mad at everybody there cuz I was like
the only reason I even came here is cuz
I wanna meet my mama
and they didn't whip it send me a video
and I watch that video every night for
so long I still be me I ain't emotional
I'm not 50 I'm very happy these are
tears of joy because you know you got to
so many things in life and you just
you'll be having these dreams that you
just really wanted to come true in it
some days you'd be like name is never
gonna happen
she sent me she call me I hang up and
I'll be like thank you so much guys
she is extraordinary she's gonna be
kicking ass in this film and I'm so glad
I got to be in it and play her mother
you know I have Tim for for the day
because it's you and it's in its TP and
you know
[Music]
if I close this deal I'll be the first
black woman to be at VP in the company
hi mom hey listen it's your sister she's
good now if you could pick her up I'd
appreciate it
what time what time honey it's Jail
you get it when you can like the song
said roaches in your net what is this a
kid man I need a job don't you just work
here what you want to put plenty is a
bit much how can I help
what they say you were sitting in line
all this time if you don't know what you
want okay you could just stand right
there and think about it Charlie Charlie
he is an amazing guy she met him or
minor year ago but she's never even seen
him he seemed too good to be true if the
man looks too good to be true here
you're being catfished
so to do a real anybody we need to go
and find this son of a [ __ ] who
catfished it and we gonna tear his ass
up this should be good
[Music]
girl I got his address we don't do this
today we don't need a saw some plastic
burner [ __ ] I can't go to the bathroom
that's good you need to go ahead and let
all the liquids out cuz you don't want
to leave no DNA you're not healthy every
time you try to kill the man you go
squirt a little Pete I know that for
sure this connection is so reckoning
hello what you wouldn't wake up I'm
sorry what we nah don't know cell phone
line I can't hear you baby I can't
[Music]